see I knew you'd be back cuz you got
nothing better to do now you come over
here and do something for your instead
click the link below and establish the
house of Allah get yourself a house in
Paradise with a superb high
level for yourself that will continue
click the link
below many of you have heard the news
about the infamous Quran burner Salan
Muma found dead in Norway
so what's the story behind this person
he was a Infamous evil person burning
the Quran making news all over the world
and putting Sweden into a position where
they were being denied entrance into
NATO because of his Quran Bannings and
the Turkish president and the Muslim
Community or overall all over the world
putting pressure on Sweden so Sweden
didn't want to deal with this problem
anymore
and they were going to deport him to
Iraq alhamdulillah going back to where
he belongs so he felt that he will be in
problems now so he thought let me escape
Sweden and go to Norway Norway is a
welcoming country we love Quran burners
in Norway so let me go to Norway and
start burning the Quran there and create
tensions and problems and divide the
community over there so he went to
Norway and then the news spread that
he's been found
dead the news was
false he was not found dead but he was
found in the custody of the police he
was arrested by the police and the
Norwegian government they considered him
a security threat to the nation now why
would they allow someone like that
coming over here and creating tensions
that's not their problem they have their
own Quran Banis creating problems some
tensions already why would they allow
this one to come here so they have
decided to deport him back to Sweden and
from there he will inshallah be deported
back to Iraq so he so he has now made
the claim that he has been it is as if
he has been given a death sentence by
the Norwegian government because he
feels that if he if he gets deported
back to Iraq then that's the end of
him but regardless of what happens to
him these Quran
burners they have awakened the Muslim
umah they have woken up something within
us a passion a a love for the religion
of Islam we do not stand by and look at
these people desecrating and humiliating
the book of Allah we will never be quiet
and these people they think that by
burning the Quran
that they will extinguish the light of
Allah they want to see us do reactionary
things attack them fight them but we
Muslims are smarter than that every
single time they BN the Quran every
single time they made the headlines what
did we do we raised money in their names
to establish the mega Masjid in Norway a
huge
da Center so they are trying to
extinguish the light of Allah with their
mouths as Allah said in the
Quran they want to extinguish the light
of Allah with their
mouths but Allah will
refuse accept but to perfect his light
even though
the they hate
it
it is he who sent his messenger with the
religion of Truth to manifest it over
all other religions to make it Prevail
even though these mus they hate it so
brothers and sisters we're now in the
last 10 nights of Ramadan today is the
27th night it may
be this is the best time the best time
for you to establish a s for yourself to
give for the sake of Allah to donate to
invest in
your to establish the religion of Allah
and show these enemies of Islam that
every single time they try to lift a
finger against the book of Allah against
the Muslims to extinguish the light of
Allah then this Ayah will be
implemented that we Muslims will
implement this Ayah that they will see
that Allah will perfect his light and we
Muslims are here to make the religion of
Islam Prevail make it
dominant give it Isa give it Glory by
establishing this religion so brothers
and sisters be part of this historic
project historic project and people will
know and they already know million
dollars was raised here in Norway by
these Quran
bers inspiring us
Muslims to fight back with our sodaka
and with enlightening the people with
the message of the Quran and that's the
best thing you can do so click the link
and give for the sake of Allah it may be
tonight and you will not get the reward
of just a single oneof donation but you
will get the reward of giving sodaka and
establishing the religion of Islam for a
[Music]
lifetime